All right, I hope that went well. We
will now talk about the most flexible query mechanism
in Datastore. Query by kind, filter by property. Let's
say you would like to query for all conferences
that are in a particular city, for example
Halloween, and with a specific topic like movie making,
and then sort the matching entries by conference name.
For example, if we were to write this out
it could look like this. Retrieve all conferences that
are in the city Halloween, and has moving making
in the topic. Sort the result by name. This
is an example of query by kind, filter by property,
since we are using property values in the search
and the sort. Let's look at this a little
bit closer. We want to have an exact match
for the city since we are only interested in conferences
in Halloween. This is called an equality filter.
Then, we want to further restrict the queries
so that only entities which has movie making
in the topic are displayed. This is called a
member of filter. We are combining these with
the and operator, meaning that both of these conditions
must be true. And finally, we are sorting
the result by name. Let's look at filters and
how you can use them to construct a query in
more detail. The first filter is the equality filter, that
we used for city in our example. Then, we have
the member of filter, which has the same symbol as
the equality filter. This filter, we use to sort by
topic. Then we have a set of inequality filters, not
equal to, less than, less than or equal to, greater
than, greater than or equal to. And all of these can
be combined using the Boolean operators and, and
or. That's enough theory to get started. So
now it's time for you to add query
by kind, filter by property, to conference central.